a new federal lawsuit claims Ohio State
University received multiple warnings a
legend students were sexually abused by
a former team dr. Richard Strauss who
died in 2005 worked for 20 years at OSU
the school says more than 100 people
including former athletes and patients
at student health services have now come
forward accusing him of abuse CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Dana Jacobson
spoke with two men who are now suing the
university Dana good morning good
morning this is the third lawsuit filed
since the allegations against dr.
Richard Strauss became public in April
that's when former members of the
wrestling team spoke out now unlike the
first two this is not a class-action
suit the former patients of dr. Strauss
we spoke with say they want to make sure
their individual stories are told when I
reread this it makes me angry because
they invalidated me back then in 1995
back then Steve Schneider Hill was a
student at Ohio State he showed us the
complaint he filed after visiting
student health services to check on a
lump in his chest and it's really clear
it's just somebody taking handwritten
notes my words he told a school
representative that his conversation
with dr. Richard Strauss felt flirty and
not at all appropriate he reported that
the doctor pushed his groin against him
and gave him unnecessary testicular and
rectal exams he was a doctor I was a
student I went in there vulnerable I was
even more vulnerable because he had me D
clothed and I'm sitting there in front
of him and everything's going really
badly were there points within the exam
where you thought I should say something
but I don't know what to do where this
is strange no when it was happening to
me I was literally letting it happen
because I didn't know how to respond to
it
after Schneider Hill reported the
incident the Director of Student Health
Services wrote a letter saying they had
never received a complaint about dr.
Strauss before but Ron McDaniel says
Strauss's behavior had been an open
secret for years so your coach was aware
of what you said happened oh yeah the
former Ohio State tennis player says he
informed a team trainer and fellow
athletes that dr. Strauss touched him
inappropriately while treating a cold in
1982 and they started laughing and they
were like ah you got hit your
you didn't know and I was like what know
what and they were like you could go to
him for a hangnail and he has to check
your testicles and we just laughed
yeah they laughed about as in it's
absurd and it's like you got hit you're
a rookie okay welcome to the club like
we all went through it we kind of
validate each other
McDaniel and Snider Hill are among 10
men who filed a new lawsuit against Ohio
State University accusing the school of
fostering an ingrained culture of
institutional indifference that
succeeded in keeping dr. Strauss is two
decades of serial sexual abuse buried
Strauss died by suicide in 2000 five
years after retiring from Ohio State so
how many victims have you heard from so
far dozens attorney Jack Lance kroner
says he hopes this legal action will
bring about change what's the goal of
the lawsuit basically the university
turned a blind eye to a serial sexual
harasser and we want to make sure that
never happens again
Ohio State launched an independent
investigation in April a spokesman says
we are aware of reports that individuals
at the University did not respond
appropriately during that era these
allegations are troubling and are a
critical focus of the current
investigation we thought we were doing
the right thing and telling our coach
David the athletic department we look to
the coaches the trainers and the doctors
to do the right thing and I mean we are
kids we were kids yeah they may have a
job to protect us and not only did they
not protect us but they subjected us to
that guy over and over and over again
and then when I tried to stand up for
people they shut me down
along with acknowledgment of wrongdoing
the men are asking for an unspecified
amount of money in damages in their
season this is the same doctor that
Congressman Jim Jordan has gotten
involved with work people are accusing
him of ignoring charges back in the day
he was an assistant on the wrestling
team an assistant coach on the wrestling
team at the time this is the same doctor
as far as they can tell right now from
the investigation in the suits 14 team
sports may be involved but again Steve
the man that we talked with was just a
student at health services so it goes
beyond just the athletic
an open secret Thank You Dana thank you